in honor of supernatural recently
getting renewed for another season we
thought it'd be fun to do a gag reel
reaction to the latest season we just
finished supernatural got another season
that's friggin awesome
now dude it's just uh it was just an
April Fool's joke I was making you think
you're always pulling [ __ ] like this
getting me excited about your book you
man season four gag reel coming your way
guys over at our patreon page we out do
a weekly podcast driven by your question
submissions once a week but the main
drive of our patreon page is our TV show
reaction watch alongs and many of those
shows have reaction highlights included
sup you don't want to sing up you could
watch a little cut that we put together
ourselves no shows are supernatural just
got to the fifth season hell yeah just
start up Doctor Who attack on Titan
death note my hero academia movie
included Code Geass Hunter hunter one
punch man
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood promise
Neverland and then their shows are we
just do watch along for them who chose
our agents of shells Gotham cover cast
season to start who thinks isn't
three-game at its final season Black
Mirror season 5 haunting a Hell House
the Mandalorians season 1 and then
there's music video reactions weekly but
the main thing people are there for is
supernatural so let's do this
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it
you
[Laughter]
that's just your awesome
Zach in that
I'm going yeah Russia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
or my pants over here
oh no monsters that's right
that has to happen oh yeah high kick
[Music]
[Applause]
I think I can do that here click hey
zero sir Epson yeah Barry Bostwick
there is a humorist radical
Oh even your real go away
that's cool the crew gets some love
all the teddy
there's a lot of stuff this season
yeah I wonder if that plate of like a
wrap party oh wow
go to myspace calm I want swing oh yeah
dude myspace is still around for music
yeah I logged into my old account logged
right back out of my home I was a
delight as always I feel like this of
all the bloopers we've seen as the most
just sort of like facial expressions
oriented when there was just a lot of
goofy quick cut hijinks I feel like some
of them had more like scene oriented
stuff yeah they looked like the the gags
kind of play out longer the other ones
this one was like quick cuts of every
single thing you know maybe there was
less room to mess around this season
because of how heavy everything is it
always strikes me as odd when it's a
blooper during one of the really serious
teens especially yes seriously yeah like
there were serious moments where I was
like oh I remember like kind of tearing
up at that scene and then he oh he
really they're just [ __ ] around what
the hell oh yeah they're like how many
important scenes smelled like a fart
when they were being shot at I made it
into the show I always find myself yeah
coming out of these with a weird little
esoteric wonders to have I would hate to
film with that oh my god have you so
gross okay how close I be with that
individual I would be like oh no I want
to quit the show that's well I did and
yeah I mean with the amount of times it
seems like it happens it seems like it
would be something that if you had a
real objection you could quit over it so
he's getting away my preparation why is
he so gassy I don't know manases I mean
I'm sure he's without a healthy boys
diet yeah that man all that fiber he has
to do in order to stay lean I imagine is
probably what it all comes down to yeah
manses oatmeal every meal the day this
crew looks like they have such a blast
together
oh yeah there was ever a drama or some
show like this that ever felt like the
crew and cast were really a family it
seems to be this show especially by this
point I think it's kind of cool Ian
enough to there's a whole bunch of
arcing to do in blooper reels but I'd
like that this one was the most crew
heavy one of them all yeah and I had a
pretty good amount of guest stars in it
too and even Bobbie Gus it was fun
watching the ones who are so serious
- yeah yeah cuz like Bobby is always
stepping up especially this season with
like the tough love I always hope for
like a full on Bobby blooper bit right
right like we're getting closer but you
know I still want that itch scratched oh
well this was a lot of fun man yeah fun
into a very harrowing season the next
one we'll watch will probably another
convention one from her friend ash
supernatural conventions those usually
give us a lot to talk about like this
video yeah happy they laughed here we
laughs yeah remember this joke that made
us laugh I do yeah you know who was
barely in this Misha Collins it made me
appreciate some of the episodes that I
kind of wasn't a big fan of - like
what's the one where they're in the
alternate timeline but I got a dream
from Zachariah yeah yeah yeah where Dean
has to choose the life and he always
will makes it easier to look back at
that episode or if I ever really watch
it going yeah they had a lot of fun that
day you know I'm having a lot more fun
they really messed with that elevator I
was sitting there going do they have
people working the doors is the dummy or
is this a real build I hope you feel
like it looked like a dummy which is
cool little bit of behind-the-scenes
knowledge and the shoot on location what
yeah yeah
which is nice because you know at a
certain point I think you'd start to
recognize the same backlog alright guys
well supernatural season 5 we have just
made it's used to go to our patreon page
day for all them goodies ok
piece B we're done now